da sprechen wir jetzt mit dem man mit
dem das alles begann der fdp
landtagsabgeordnete thomas kemmerich aus
thüringen der damals mit stimmen von cdu
fdp und eben auch der afg zum
ministerpräsidenten gewählt wurde hallo
herr kemmerich
hallo guten tag ja zuerst die frage an
sie natürlich freut sie dieses urteil
nein ich hatte keine emotion daran
[Musik]
ich hätte mich geärgert wenn es anders
ausgegangen wird so freue ich mich auch
nicht ich bin ein mensch der sein leben
badehaus richtig nach vorne zu schauen
der sachverhalt ist ausreichend erklärt
weil das dreieinhalb jahre her und
wollte hat eine juristische
interpretation gegeben mehr ist es nicht
und bilder aber trotzdem wird es
sicherlich in irgendeiner form bewegen
es geht ja um sie haben ja bestimmt auch
heute nach karlsruhe geschaut so ein
bisschen genugtuung spürt man da doch
sicherlich und
nein es ging nicht um welches ging um
das was die richter auf sich gestellt
haben
inwieweit muss ein politiker in seinen
abend neutralität wahren das ist heute
gegenstand des obstes gewesen ich bin
vielleicht der anlass aber es ging nicht
um mich und deshalb gibt es neben wie
gestern und morgen
unbeeindruckt durch dieses urteil oder
die richterspruch aber es war ja damals
auch ihre entscheidungen so zu handeln
versetzen sie sich doch noch mal in die
lage von damals vor zwei jahren wie war
das schwierige koalitionsbildung viel
druck sie wollten ein linksbündnis
unbedingt verhindern würden sie es noch
mal genauso machen
darüber ist viel geschrieben worden und
die fakten des falls sich glaube ich
ausreichend erklärt die viele
interpretationen der wirklich nichts
neues hinzuzufügen
auf ihre frage konkret mit dem wissen
von heute und die hochzeit ist immer
relativ leicht mit dem wissen von in der
zukunft gewonnen die dinge schon damals
zu beurteilen dann würde man sicherlich
anders handeln
die
ereignisse wie sie am ende abgelaufen
sind sagen zwar viele kommentatoren bahn
absehbar waren aber in dem moment
vielleicht nicht so klar aber man muss
inzwischen einen sehen dass die afg eben
mit den mitteln der demokratien versucht
die demokratie zu beschädigen so auch
mit steinen kandidaten und insofern
müsste man drin wenn es tatsächlich noch
mal zu einem ähnlich gelagerten fall
kommt die sache anders einschätzen und
sich jetzt anders handeln sie sind ja
auch damals bange zurückgetreten nach
nur einem tag werden die bilder auch
gerade noch gesehen susanne henning welt
so von den linken die waffen dann noch
ein blumenstrauß vor die füße wie fühlt
sich das an und füllten sie sich damals
in diesem moment ungerecht behandelt
ach das ist das geht gegen alles in
sekundenschnelle an jemanden war mir
vorbei das habe ich mir immer erinnern
auch noch mal in ruhe angeschaut und mir
dann auch ein bruchteil gebildet in dem
moment hat man eher
ist man durch die situation durch das
soll keine entschuldigung sein jeder
kann auch beurteilen was er von einem
von diesem sogenannten blumen drauf zu
halten hat nochmals der sache ist
ausreichend beschrieben
interpretationen bewertung und viele
viele leute vorgenommen den wenig keine
weitere hinzufügen ich glaube auch über
die situation die sie gerade beschrieben
haben kommen sie viele leute investiert
und wie gesagt den will ich zu viel wie
haben sie denn damals angela merkels
aussage wahrgenommen hatten sie
eigentlich jemals danach noch
persönlichen kontakt zu ihr konnten sie
sich darüber austauschen
nein das hat dann wurden aus der stadt
gefunden ich habe es wie wir alle aus
der presse erfahren
aber dass viele in den kontext sich
insgesamt
sehr dynamische entwicklungen in diesen
24 stunden insofern habe ich das gar
nicht so wahrgenommen und zwar genug
trubel in und um meine person in und um
erfurt und mein aus dass das auch im
nachhinein erst ganz deutlich wurde was
und wo das überhaupt möchten sie gerne
vielleicht heute noch was sagen sie
können es jetzt gerne loswerden
nein das medium eignet sich nicht dazu
in irgendeiner form
da sich zu häusern noch mal beim politik
geht es nicht darum seine persönlichen
empfindlichkeiten irgendwo den
vordergrund zu stellen die hat jeder
aber ich bin ladens position der freien
demokraten hier in thüringen nimmt
jährigen unheimlich viele aufgaben vor
der brust zu lösen es geht um tür dem
viertürigen und ich glaube in meiner
politischen arbeit und dafür lohnt sich
jetzt auch hier mit ihnen diese und und
gebe aufgrund meiner politischen arbeit
als ich mich dann nicht von den
emotionen und von ihrem los leisten ich
richte mein blick auch ein viertüriges
und vor allen dingen formen die zukunft
ich möchte ihnen zum schluss noch ein
zitat von fdp-justizminister marco
buschmann aus ihrer partei zeigen jetzt
auf twitter geschrieben und die afg
kritisiert die bundesverfassung das
bundesverfassungsgericht er schreibt er
entscheidet bei äußerungen von kanzlerin
merkel für antrag der afg das ist kein
sieg das sagt er sondern ein
historisches eigentor denn das widerlegt
die afg in ihrem grund mythos der auf
dem schüren von zweifeln an demokratie
und rechtsstaatlichkeit in deutschland
aufbaut was sagen sie hat zu flechten
sie ihn bei
dass ich möchte dass man durchaus
weiblichen flächen und relationen die
afg erleben wir nicht nur ein thema land
sage euch insbesondere durch
ihren sogenannten ersten mal ein wenig
müde lächelt er sich vielleicht hier und
da mal das kleid eines bürgerlichen
versuchten über zu ziehen aber wenn die
kameras an anderer stelle laufen wenn er
auf marktplätzen nur steht wird der
bücher schreibt dann kommt dass er seine
faschistische und rückwärts geliebten
rückwärtsgewandte gesinnung heraus das
muss jedem klar sein dass hier jemand
einem
richterspruch erwirkt hat der mit allen
mitteln versucht die demokratie zu
bekämpfen fast lächerlich zu machen
gegen das system
mir gefällt wie schon gesagt wird
anzukämpfen und deshalb sollten ja in
keinster weise das als sieg oder jemand
man es sagen mag für die afg werten die
richter haben sehr nüchtern über den
allgemeinen fall beurteilt wie sich
politiker im amt zu verhalten haben ihre
persönliche meinungsäußerungen das ist
es auch schon die hat ihn krank so
weiterhin sieg geworden und wir sollten
alles daran tun insbesondere den weg die
aus menschen motivation auch immer ihr
kreuz bei der fdp machen ganz klar zu
erklären und aufzuklären was hinter der
afg und insbesondere hinter den
funktionären ihren thüringen auch an
anderer stelle steckt nochmals oftmals
und wortgewandte reaktionäre kräfte die
nichts gutes mit unserem publikum auge
habe und den thüringer aber die
situation dass leidet ja de und die
linkspartei die auch in ihren reihen
linksgerichtete nichts auf die
verfassungsgebende menschen beherbergt
und will beheimatet die mehrheit haben
das macht diesen tieren besonders schwer
und wir sollten alles daran tun dass wir
die politischen also die afg politik
macht da kann man ruhig besten dank für
ihre offenen worte hier heute bei uns
bei bet live sehr gerne schönen tag
machen